LET'S GO TO RACHEL.
>> Rachel: CHRIS PAUL, I KNOW
YOU'RE ALL OVER THE PLACE RIGHT
NOW.
CHRIS PAUL IS IN THE NBA FINALS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WHEN YOU HEAR
THAT SENTENCE?
>> MAN, IT SOUNDS DAMN GOOD.
DAMN GOOD.
BEEN A LOT OF WORK, MAN.
A LOT OF WORK.
GOING TO A NEW TEAM, EVERYBODY
SAYING, OF COURSE, THAT TEAM
FIGHT HARD.
TLUE, UNBELIEVABLE COACH AND
CHAUNCEY BILLUPS, MY BRINGING
BROTHER AND SO MANY TIES TO THAT
TEAM.
BUT DAMN, THIS FEELS GOOD.
>> Rachel: IN THIS GAME, CHRIS,
THERE WAS A POINT THE CLIPPERS
CUT IT TO SEVEN.
YOU THEN SCORED 14 OF 16 POINTS
ON YOUR WAY TO 41 FOR THE GAME.
WHAT KIND OF MISSION WERE YOU
ON?
>> DON'T LOSE.
DON'T LOSE MISSION.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
DAMN, THAT FEEL GOOD.
I WISH MY SON AND MY FAMILY COME
DOWN HERE.
I DON'T KNOW.
MAN, A LOT OF EMOTIONS AND A LOT
OF INJURIES.
I WAS GETTING AN MRI ON MY WRIST
GOING ON ON.
I APPRECIATE YOU, RACHEL.
>> Rachel: I'LL TALK TO YOU WHEN
I GIVE YOU THE TROPHY.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
BACK TO YOU, MIKE.
>> Mike: YOU CAN HEAR THE
EMOTION IN HIS VOICE.
AGAIN, IT'S TAKEN HIM 16 YEARS.
ONE OF THE PREMIER POINT GUARDS
THROUGHOUT HIS ENTIRE CAREER.
NOW AT AGE 36.
I REMEMBER A FEW YEARS AGO
PEOPLE WERE STARTING TO SAY HE
WAS ON HIS DECLINE.
WHAT HE DID LAST YEAR WAS
MAGNIFICENT WITH OKC, JUST
GETTING THEM INTO THE PLAYOFFS.
AND THEN THIS YEAR, COMES TO A
PHOENIX SUNS TEAM THAT HAD NOT
BEEN TO THE PLAYOFFS SINCE 2010
AND HERE THEY ARE IN THE NBA
FINALS.
EVERY SIM ONE OF THESE YOUNG
PLAYERS TALKED ABOUT THE IMPACT
THAT HE'S HAD.
SO NOW THEY WILL AWAIT THE
WINNER OF THE EAST AND THAT IS
GOING TO RESUME TOMORROW NIGHT
ON TNT.
GAME FIVE AND TIP-OFF